mika c'est l'heure de s'affronter
vous n'êtes pas être bio de monde c'est
idiot
wahou merrill lynch ou engage
aujourd'hui je trouve sur gomme beast
que ce soit alors ce jour là précis
alors on a déjà fait que ce serait nier
mais il ya quelques jours je crois que
j'étais venu loi mais par contre comme
toi bizarrement je voir beaucoup plus de
ce qu'il est l'homme quatre champs bleus
c'est moi contre le renard vert de mika
connard hathaway je perd d'entrée de jeu
quoique tu veux rejoindre quoi as tu
t'es un sommet à la base il un bad vient
pas de dessin vient de battre kaunas
moi je t'attrape je t'attrape c'est faux
j'ai attrapé le cam laisse parle je
t'attrape web est soit bien au delà à
savoir que les bras attends je suis
carrément partie en vogue
on n'a jamais vu ça dans la vraie vie je
suis pendu et tuyaux nuls 6 arrêts bien
c'est cool je vais lâcher mais non mais
sa vie là je t'ai laissé les trois
points d'avance francophone after that
he might ont blagué limoges bgc moi je
danse et voilà la technique de la danse
personne ne l'a vu venir celle là haut
la main face à bath il casse la vitre
avec ça tout est un atout trop fort avec
la pensée il devait tomber
non mais c'est un sketch pourquoi il
s'accroche pas mal et le pire mal
d'humour de la cette manne j'adore parce
que souvent dessus je gagne cacher mon
gars là j'avais tort qu'ils
connaissaient l'existence de sa gamme
assainie chemin de fer d'asie remonte
non-fumeurs attend jamais j'ai été sauvé
à jeu tu as fait
voilà je te mets un petit coup de tête
ça a bien passé ça se passe bien et cas
où je t'ai mis ko là je touche nom est
tu dégages
ne pas s'approcher au poteau c'est sûr
tu veux penser accroché au poteau la
vérité choc dont trois deux un
il est le savez la [ __ ] mais vous
coincez face à deux à l'heure là au
[ __ ] je trouve ça t'apprendra à faire
superman vi car non mais non mais c'est
un sketch mon gamme énorme mec c'est bon
là les mecs je vais tomber dessus vient
de battre la lave en u au réseau wi et
l'acheteur aux bateaux aux attaques et
sauf qu'elle vole du rgo nada et mikado
insue secondes mais tu vas dormir je
reviens jamais le temps c'est précieux
hélas
il fait des fans de ces deux mecs
assommé cô te mets un petit coup de tête
au jeu des cerveaux c'est moi qui te
sourit non au alors la mort alors là
mais les récolteurs ça c'était pour
qu'il faut c'est non non non mais
comment tu fais pour sauter alors t'as
pas d'appuis mais je suis en renard à 8
h allez mon frère tu vas mourir c'est
fini pour toi mais car c'est vous venez
pour toi vikalo t ou non mais t'es
attend les moeurs te plaire moment
ayasse et démarre bien la vie car tu vas
décédé michael tu le sais au fond de toi
fond de toi tu sais que tu vas décès à
nantes a gagné alors là c'est la
troisième manche lui qui gagnent il a
tout gagné c'est une règle et ça
m'avantage vraiment pas c'est ça le pire
est-ce qu'elle revend pas de zéro alors
là alors là tu sais très bien qu'il doit
finir dans le feu mika yards mais j'suis
à sauver je t'aime tu vas perdre qu'est
ce tu vas te sers toi ce mur va croiser
la regarde la chose ah là là là oh là là
mais ce style sa salle mais j'ai pas
envie de faire ce mot là là non hélas
hélas je te chauffe
c'était violent ce qui s'est passé je
tâche très bon prix je te balance
merci à tous merci pour vos
applaudissements mais non et comme par
hasard c'est que bana moi je reste en
bas secondes les kids patron je reste
zen
alors je te jure que pour une fois pour
une fois c'est pas moi qui ai fait ça
parce que j'étais en difficulté
moi je pense que du coup on va partir
sur une égalité non parce que là
j'allais gagner clairement non mais on
fait une mode game c'est la belle mika
ce week end c'est de gagner et pas
d'euro coup de boule si je te vois versa
tu es limité talent à thala bon je
rétablis à règles du coup de boule ok
c'est au nom et à dieu non pourquoi
jamais de la vie c'est une mort à reste
à faire nous voilà bien avancés fiche
des voeux ok 3 partout non non non non
non non non au yes ou yes yes me suis
emporté non coûteux mais je sais pas je
vais faire super plus tard à ménerbes
que j'arrivais patate au wat au foot
alors vas-y bien non oui non au oui non
ces labels complètement partout rien de
dauchy de dos comme les héros dans
l'animé oculaire ok mais on en fait pas
ça aux les gens vont te tuer
et du coup tu parais infatué j'écoute va
arrête mais qu'a fait mal qu'on l'a
choisi et harvard en jeu je te tiens par
la calvitie quoi wiimakes au oui le
match est réhaussée du bon match c'était
super fils de [ __ ] j'ai adoré je suis
fair play [ __ ] écoute je vais
trimestre ont reculé de ta mère le
trophée une tasse voilà j'espère que ça
plaît bon je te mets fouet je suis
atteint 2 7 et 2 018 ne sait pas aimer
ça vous a plus bas mais khartoum a battu
je te propose qu'on se retrouve sur
roquettes ligue la prochaine fois et
celui qui gagne requête ligue a gagné
toutes les vidéos depuis qu'on se
connaît et oui et je dis pas ça parce
que j'en ai bien dit qu'une sur dix
alors je t'aime pas une prochaine vidéo
ciao tout le monde partait ou bien alors
c'est bien